anyway uh the games are not
starting there it is
okay am i on the wrong cam
no i'm not on the wrong cam okay never
mind
the game has started he's played one d4
let's go artemis is
um young relatively young
born in 98 grandmaster from
from from russia who has a very
positional
style of play i would say at this point
he's definitely a top top five
blitz player in the world so this is
clearly a very tough challenge
okay let me um try and uh
play something
slightly unusual here i'll go
yeah let's go knight bd7
a6 there's queen b3
i feel like i've been stalling in this
exact position before
okay let's go c6
you can go bishop d3 but i feel like
rook c1 is a
it's a waste of time probably
if not a waste of time then
maybe not necessary because how are
these lines 27
castles e5
d95 takes 95 maybe
it's a little bit dull
yeah i don't know what else to do though
so i'm thinking
this knight d5 cd5
bishop d2 queen d2 queen d5
should be more or less equal
and if he takes him d5 immediately
then i have bishop c3 and then e4
winning a piece
so i think this is fine
if cd5 i will have to cons i will have
to consider
whether to go cd or
or 95 yeah but this this is what i
expected though
and
i may be very slightly worse
but i think realistically it's just
gonna end up
equal
and i don't know why he's
his thinking um
regardless i think yeah
this is pretty much pretty much equal
maybe i can hope some point
to have chances with the majority
hoping that it's easier to set it three
against two in motion
than four four against three
um but i think it's unrealistic
anyway now g6
feels like the sensible way to get luft
25
yeah this is uh
pretty pretty cool i think
should be six yeah
capture so his idea is
capture rook c4 rook d8
and then rook d4 trying to get control
over the
d file that's clever
probably don't have a lot of choice
attack
so queen e7 queen c7 maybe
you can see someone there's still queen
d1
maybe i'm actually slightly worse
okay let's go b6 rook d7
maybe this forcing queen d1 at least
maybe it was a queen of six rook a7 rook
d8
looks like counter plane huh
at least in blitz this seems reasonable
if it doesn't take i just go rook d8 and
i exchange and
i'm never never ever worse
yeah i just realized 58 quincy three
when i lose
hmm
yeah there are no tricks there
it's a pity okay queen of three rk7
there's r8
yeah he's not much better but he's
certainly slightly better and
it's hard to hard to imagine me winning
h4 i go h5
okay he decides just a trade
i think that's oh maybe i don't have a
perpetual there
no i think i'm fine i'll give a check
oh he still has f3
that's a pity yeah then i'm
just much worse
i should still have good chances to hold
but now it's definitely suffering
and i should have put the king on on g8
as well
okay c5
trying to exchange queen d1 quinn
oh my god i just keep on blundering i
thought i had this check but
hmm
not good not good okay i'll try and
fight of course but now
feels like a lost cause at this point
it's been awful
how does he intend to keep everything
together
okay this way makes sense
okay queen d7 i'm going for queen h3
yeah i'm just hoping for tricks at this
point
but he's getting shorter time maybe i
can
yeah i know i think i'm saving it enough
it's unbelievable
unbelievable
this is no good
take
[Music]
wow
i'll take it i guess
i will take it